The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So class
1 as you all will recall
was about direct
innovation factors.
And we looked at the growth
economists, Solow and Romer
in particular.
And they essentially gave us
two direct innovation factors
that you really can't account
for in an innovation system
unless those are inputs.
So what we could
translate Solow as saying,
you need to do R&D. And we
can translate Romer as saying,
you need to--
it's the talent in
the system that's
working in this system
that's a critical input.
So that gives us our first
two innovation factors.
Class 2 brought us our third.
And we began to consider
innovation as not just factors,
but as a system.
And Liz Reynolds' discussion
earlier this afternoon
was a good reminder of a
systems approach to innovation.
So we read Richard
Nelson, and he
introduced the idea of looking
at national innovation systems.
He wasn't the first
to use that term.
Chris Freeman at the
University of Sussex
was, but he really
explored the dimensions
and taught us to look
at the innovation
institutions and the
strengths and weaknesses
of those institutions.
And with that
concept then, you can
begin to explore any
innovation system.
Our third direct
innovation factor,
then, is really all about
innovation organization.
The strength of the actors, the
connections between the actors,
and then the gaps in
that innovation system.
You can analyze all of
those and understand a lot
about the strength of a
particular innovation system,
whether it's national,
whether it's regional,
whether it's local.
And Liz gave you a
reading of her study
of the state of
Massachusetts, which
is a good glimpse
into those issues.
So classes 3 and 4 I
won't recap because Liz
gave us a good reminder
of those issues.
But we studied manufacturing,
and how it evolved
in two different periods--
both the 1980s competition
period and the current decline
of US manufacturing in the
first decade of this century,
the early 2000s.
And that was a good
case study for us
on how to take these
ideas of innovation system
and look at a system,
the manufacturing system.
Class 5 pulled back and
got us into the framework
again, looking at innovation
at the institutional level.
How does R and D and
prototype, how do those stages
operate in innovation
organizations, R
and D organizations?
And then, how does
the handoff occur
in an innovation system and
the strength of those actors
as well?
So that got us into thinking
about looking at innovation
at the institutional level.
Class number six was about
the Valley of Death problem.
The gap that was in effect
built in into the US innovation
system because we focused
the federal role on research,
it didn't really focus on
the follow-on later stage
development in
subsequent stages, right?
So it guaranteed a gap
between our innovation actors,
between the research world
and the implementation world.
And we talked about innovation
at the face-to-face level.
So innovation doesn't just occur
at the institutional level,
it occurs amongst people.
People innovate,
not institutions.
Institutions help organize
an innovation system,
but in the end it's people.
And what are the rule sets that
govern the way innovation looks
like at the face-to-face level?
And we got deeply into
great group theory.
Class number 8 was
about DARPA, which
is a very different innovation
model than the bulk of the US
system, organized around--
predominately around they end
of the World War II time period.
It's an organization
that attempts
to combine capabilities at
both the institutional level,
but also the great
group forming innovation
at the face-to-face level.
Working on
breakthrough technology
is what DARPA calls
a right/left model.
It wants to think
about what it gets out
of the end of the
innovation system.
It's not just curiosity-driven.
So what do they
want, and then how
to go back to the early
stages and develop
the breakthroughs to get there?
So a very different
organizational model.
Class 9 was a case study on NIH.
And again it brought
home to us how
to look at an innovation
system, in this case,
in the life science
research world.
And what are the institutional
barriers and problems
in that system?
Class 10 was around
energy technology,
we introduced the idea of
the difficulty of innovating
in a legacy economic sector--
and established,
complex, existing legacy
sector that builds up its
own paradigm to protect
its models that
are technological,
they are economic, they are
political, they are social.
And they build barriers
to disruptive threats
from the outside,
from new entrants
that would attempt to
disrupt that model.
And how do you begin to think
about bringing innovation
into these legacy sectors is
a really important question,
because most of the
economy is legacy sectors.
And if you're walling off
80% or more of your economy
from innovation, then you're
going to dramatically affect
your ability to grow,
and your growth rate,
and your societal well-being.
So in effect that's the
problem with legacy sectors,
and that's the need--
that's the reason why
we need to figure out
how to innovate in them.
Class 11 was all
about education.
Again, another legacy sector.
And we talked about
a whole set of ways
to think about science
education, technology
education, and then education
for innovation itself.
Could we ever attempt to
think about that as a teaching
approach?
And today will be all about
the future work, which
I think is an issue that is
going to affect all of you,
and will kind of dominate
a lot of your time
over ensuing decades.
So we're going to try and sort
this one out and try and figure
out what it means by
reading some of the leading
thinkers in this area.
And then Liz was great
by doing the whole--
innovation is like real estate.
It's location,
location, location.
So it really forms in
these geographic regions.
You really need to understand
it in geographical region.
We didn't have time for
everything in this class,
but that's certainly one
of the classes I would
have added if I had the time.
So Liz walked us through some
of those initial concepts
in that field, which she does
really important work in,
by the way.
All right you've got
Brynjolffson Johnson
and you've got the
first David Autor piece.
So why don't I do
those together,
because they're they
critique each other, right?
And this is a big debate that's
going on, on the MIT campus
with different perspectives
here as we're going to see,
about what's going to
happen to work here.
And so after the
Great Recession,
the economy went through
a very slow period
of putting people back to work.
Now, we're now back to
5% or lower employment,
but we still have a large number
of people that never went back
into the workforce.
A shockingly high number.
So this problem-- we're
not past this problem.
So this is an early piece by
Erik Brynjolffson and Andrew
McAfee.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
Brynjolffson.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Forgive me, Tom.
AUDIENCE: Just in case--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
No, I appreciate it.
I'm glad we're going
to get that right.
AUDIENCE: Brynjolffson.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Brynjolfsson.
All right.
Good.
So Eric and Andrew--
how's that-- brought us a
whole set of new thinking
about this territory.
And there's a debate about
what their findings are.
This is an early
piece they produced.
Their book on this topic is
called The Second Machine Age.
So they looked at
this problem of why
wasn't the economy
putting people back
to work at a rate that
was more acceptable?
And they argued that
the 2007, 2008 recession
wasn't a typical
business cycle recession.
In other words, you didn't lose
your job and then get it back.
You lost your job, period.
Right?
Your job did not come
back after this recession,
in many sectors,
particularly manufacturing
as we talked about.
So one explanation was, gee,
it's just not a normal business
cycle.
It's stagnation.
And there's a long-term
decline in certain sectors
that you have to
understand and look at.
A third explanation, which
they venture to set out,
was that it wasn't
really stagnation either,
and it wasn't too
little innovation--
a signal of stagnation--
it was too much
innovation for the economy
to manage and handle.
And so they embarked,
then, on kind
of a history of this concern
about the end of work,
which they argue started
in 1995 with a growing
concern at that time about
technological job displacement.
And they look at the
surrounding technologies
that are emerging--
Google's driverless
cars, Watson's Jeopardy,
Ray Kurzwell, in his book,
The Age of Spiritual Machines:
When Computers Exceed
Human Intelligence,
began to portray some
of these concerns.
In other words, people were
going to get displaced.
Their work was going
to be displaced
by the advent of the IT
technology revolution
as it moves into artificial
intelligence areas.
What is clear is that there
has been exponential growth
in the computing sector.
And computers are
thousands of times
better than they
were 30 years ago.
But there are areas that
Eric and Andrew point out,
where computers are not
good at particularly
the sort of combination of both
physical and knowledge areas,
and are not yet good at
general problem solving,
and they're not good
at creative abilities.
But there has been
exponential progress.
So there's still a significant
distance here they note.
But their concern is
that is on the way,
and it's going to disrupt
a lot of employment
in the economy over time.
And then they argue that given
that exponential advance,
there are two fundamental
strategies in response.
One is an organizational
innovation strategy.
And the core idea
here is there's
an opportunity for
creative entrepreneurs
that can create new business
models that combine the growing
numbers of mid-skilled workers
with ever-cheaper technologies
to create new kinds of value.
All right?
That could be one way
out of this unemployment
social disruption box.
And they argue that
digital technologies
do create great
opportunities for individuals
to use their own kind
of unique capabilities.
They ask, are we running
out of innovation?
And when businesses are based
on bits instead of atoms,
then each new product adds
to the set of building blocks
that are available to
the next entrepreneur,
instead of depleting
the stock of ideas.
So this truly is an exponential
growth kind of territory.
There's no denying
it, they argue.
But it does create a new
set of building blocks
that are potentially
available here
that you can think about
organizational innovation
to get around.
The second argument
they make is that we
need to make significant
investments in human capital
as a way of dealing with
this oncoming set of issues.
So improving the
education and skill sets
to get the most out of our
kind of racing technology, they
argue, is important.
And they posit that there's
a third Industrial Revolution
really around computing
and information,
which is based on
information that,
in effect, doesn't get used up.
So that's Eric and
Andrew's picture.
And it's a dark picture, right?
Their concern is
that a lot of people
are going to get left behind.
Let's frantically do
organizational reforms,
let's do other kinds of changes
in the educational system.
They argue for a
set of tax changes.
They really propose in the
end-- not in this piece,
but in later pieces-- a negative
income tax to kind of redress
the inequality wealth
balance in the society.
They're concerned that
this is upon us, right?
And then David
Autor, MIT economist
who's been doing some remarkable
work in a series of areas,
we read his work
on manufacturing.
He writes a responsive piece.
Why are There
Still so Many Jobs?
is his response.
And he argues that Eric
and Andrew are only
taking a partial look
at this phenomena.
So let's do a little bit
of historical material.
Historically,
economics has always
found that technological
advance, historically,
always creates net new jobs.
And it's been going on since
the Industrial Revolution.
And every time you study one of
these great ways of innovation,
net, there are people affected,
disrupted by the new innovation
waves, right?
Buggy whip manufacturers
had a real problem
with the advent of the
automobile internal combustion
engine, right?
So you can think about a
lot of displacement that
has occurred historically, but
net, the amount of employment
overall was a net gain.
And David said, is that
era over, is the question.
And his basic answer is no.
That's not over.
And what he would
argue, in a way,
is an assessment and
counting problem.
It's not that there is not
going to be disruption.
It's just that automation
can also complement labor
and can raise outputs
in ways that lead
to higher demand for labor.
Right?
So automation does indeed
substitute for labor,
but in this complimentary
way, automation
can also lead to new
kinds of output, that lead
to new kinds of employment.
And you've got to
understand and assess that--
the combination of these
factors, the substitution
as well as the complementarity--
in understanding what's
going to happen ahead.
And he argues that
commentators tend
to overstate the extent
of machine substitution
for the human labor and ignore
the strong complementarities
between automation and labor,
that in the end increase
productivity, raise earnings,
and augment demand for labor.
So there's one important
thing that has not changed
in the economy here, right?
So if we look at agriculture
in the 19th century,
we employed approaching-- over
40% of our population in 1900
was employed in agriculture.
Now, we employ less than 1%.
Much greater output.
So that's a story of
intense productivity gains.
But agriculture is different
than the production of goods--
non-agricultural goods.
If you look at food
consumption per human being
in the United States,
it's not very different
now than it was in 1900.
Even in America there's only so
many calories we can consume.
I mean, we're working on it.
But even here there are limits.
That's not true in the
production of goods.
We seem to have an insatiable
appetite for more goods.
And occasionally a movement
will hit society like,
let's get rid of our stuff.
But it never last very long.
So it's a different world.
We can't make the
agricultural analogy
to non-agricultural
good production, right?
They're different worlds.
And part of the
story that the David
otter is attempting
to illustrate here
is that the limit--
there is no limit
on goods, all right?
So that complementarity,
that combination
of people and machines can lead
to new kinds of technologies,
new kinds of advances,
new kinds of goods that
fit evolving sets of needs.
And he provides an interesting
example of complementarity.
He notes that ATMs, the
cash machines in every bank
that you know of, and
all over the place,
they were introduced in 1970.
The assumption at the time
was that, well, there's
not going to be any
more bank tellers.
That job is over, right?
And there were a lot of those.
But what ended up happening,
was that by 2010, there
were actually somewhat more
bank tellers, but their job
and been repurposed to not
just doing, counting up cash
and handing it to customers.
Their jobs got repurposed
into, frankly considerably more
sophisticated, customer
service kind of job.
So an upgrading of the skills
required in a way for that job,
but no loss in employment.
In fact, a very modest gain.
Despite the fact that
everybody thought
that sector was going to go.
So he argues that
that's not unique.
This is going to occur
in other sectors as well.
So the gains in
productivity have not
led to a shortfall of demand
for goods and services.
These keep growing,
which is a big offsetting
factor to the substitution
of automation for work.
And he provides an
interesting description
of how you could look at
the different economies
in recent decades,
right, the 1940 to 1970
economy versus the
current economy.
His characterization
of the economy
that has been taking hold since
1980 through the current time,
is that it's increasingly
professional and technical
with managerial occupations,
and that they're
growing pretty rapidly.
Whereas skilled blue collar
occupations are shrinking,
and that clerical and
sales occupations, which
are the kind of vulnerable
equivalent of production
jobs in the information
age, those are in decline.
There's a powerful piece
in The Economist this week
about the decline in
retail sales operations
overall in the United
States, in light
of the explosion of Amazon
and online delivery ordering
system.
And how are those changes
going to take place?
What does that look like?
And what stores-- location-based
stores are thriving
and which ones aren't, right?
It's a very
interesting assessment.
Steph?
AUDIENCE: I'm try to figure
out if this is a good time
to ask it.
I'm curious about like,
drone technology is still
not at the point in which it can
take over the entire delivery
system for a
company like Amazon,
but it seems like the
Federal Government is
defunding the Postal Service.
So what then happens to the
increase in labor, or I guess,
the increase in demand
of these products
if there isn't an equal rise
in delivery infrastructure?
I guess that would
be a consideration
that I would hope that The
Economist article would
address.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Yeah, it
doesn't deal with the Postal
Service question.
We can kind of think
it through, right?
So what happened, right?
I don't know about
the number of letters
you're writing longhand
per day these days,
but mine is not high.
So we've shift over
to online systems.
So the bulk of what
used to be mail is gone.
The Postal Service however,
missed the revolution, right?
They missed the fact that
online delivery of goods
was going to explode.
FedEx had a better model, and
they captured that marketplace.
So FedEx is thriving
hand-in-glove
with Amazon and other similar
comparable delivery systems.
The Postal Service missed
that revolution by-and-large--
although they've been
trying to catch up--
to their own detriment
over time, right?
That's kind of the story.
And when you look in
terms of net employment,
we'll see how this sorts out.
But again, this is an
example of complementarity,
the whole Federal
Express and similar--
DHL, and other express
delivery services--
that's a complimentary
service that
happened to compliment
very nicely the evolution
of the distribution
of goods originating
through online services.
So that helps us think
about some of this.
Martin?
AUDIENCE: I mean, [INAUDIBLE]
is like maybe that's
an industry that is OK
to maybe be disrupted,
because probably when it
began it wasn't profitable.
And so you needed the
government to have it,
to have it as an
infrastructure for--
it was a tool for communication.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: And there is a there's
a huge societal gain from this,
even though it
wasn't profitable.
And then with less letters, and
because you have the internet,
and probably what happened
is all these other companies
optimized their
logistics really well,
because they're getting
better and better
and they have more money, those
companies became profitable,
and it was probably way
easier and way cheaper
to send it through their way.
And now you have all
this kind of stagnation
in innovation inside that--
you have the Postal
Service, that sector.
So it just wasn't
viable for them
to keep going because it's
just it's just a huge waste.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right they?
Have a whole set
of disadvantages.
The government
handed them the task
of having to deliver
mail and parcels
to every single neighborhood
in the United States,
no matter how empty your
neighborhood was, right?
If you were out there
in rural South Dakota,
you can imagine that
the economic base
for a strong delivery system
is probably not there.
So there were a lot
of disadvantages
they faced going into
this, but in the end,
they missed that package
delivery mechanism.
But you make a
good point, Martin.
Let me wrap up with David Autor.
There is, in the end
then, an interplay
between people and machines.
And the comparative
advantage will
allow computers to substitute
for workers in performing
routine codifiable tasks.
But it also amplifies
the comparative advantage
of workers in supplying
problem solving skills,
adaptability, and creativity.
So the people-like capabilities.
And maybe computers will
get to these some decade,
but that's not happening
anytime real soon.
So re-addressing the
balance between those two
is the key to managing the
entry of these new IT-based
technologies into the economy,
David Autor would argue.
The frontier of
automation, he recognizes,
is rapidly advancing.
So the challenge of substituting
machines remains intense.
But if you focus
only on what's lost,
you miss a really central
economic mechanism.
So automation affects
the demand for labor
by raising the
value of the tasks
that workers uniquely
supply, right?
So that's-- Eric and Andrew tell
us about the challenge ahead
from the IT revolution in
substituting IT for work.
David Autor begins to
put us on a pathway
to make an assessment of just
what that's going to mean,
and what the balance
between people and machines
is going to be, and how we need
to think about that balance,
right?
So that's the core issue
in his article, how come
there's still so many jobs?
His argument in the end
is, in this territory,
there's going to be
substantial numbers of jobs.
Beth, it's all yours.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So there are a lot of really
good questions this week.
So I want to spend most of
the time discussing those.
Just a few points that I noted.
So maybe perhaps a
little differently,
I found Eric and Andrew's
piece more optimistic
than I expected.
Especially how it
ends, kind of saying
like we've been through
these revolutions before,
we'll get through this one.
Which I found kind of
weird, because they
spent most of the beginning of
the article talking about how
this was fundamentally different
given its exponential growth.
So that was a little
hard for me to reconcile.
I think they're trying to
end it a little more upbeat,
but maybe if I read
their whole book,
I'll see that it's a little
bit more nuanced than that.
And then, yeah, as Bill
said, Professor Autor kind of
portrays a different
story in that,
like, yes, we need to be
aware of these changes that
are coming, but they aren't
as bleak as we might think.
And then he also does talk--
I think it's in this article--
about how additional
technological advances,
such as machine
learning could cut
in a little bit to his
conclusions about the skills
that humans have that
are unique from machines.
But starting first with
this Eric Andrew piece,
Matt brought up a really
interesting question
that I think is
worth discussing.
So one of the things
that they talk about
is this new ecosystem will
have a lot of opportunities
for entrepreneurs.
But Matt noted that, especially
like in Silicon Valley,
we see that a lot
of IT entrepreneurs
are kind of creating apps
or other new advances that
don't have a lot of value for
economic growth, that might
just be like making like,
solving first world problems
as they like to say.
So what do you think the reality
is with these entrepreneurs
actually creating
new companies that
are going to be able
to foster job growth?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah I'll
put a quick point on that.
I would say that right
now what's happened
is that because
the IT revolution
there were these sectors that--
it's pretty much the scaling
and cycle distribution.
So things that don't
matter, you can scale,
but you make a lot
of money off them.
But we're entering a
period where people are
going to do things that matter.
And now you have
the capital markets,
you have the
infrastructure of how
you grow companies
quickly, how you on board.
So this whole infrastructure has
already been built out, right?
So the way I would compare
is like when Amazon started,
they built this
infrastructure, and it was just
to distribute books, right?
And then later, they evolved
to all these other platforms.
So the benefit now is that you
have these capital markets.
So that, say, somebody does
do like a very important
innovation to
the-- like CRISPR--
you can get it passed on faster.
So right now, I would say, like,
you should think of Snapchat,
Facebook is kind of like
little to middle leagues.
But it creates the
environment that if someone
does do something significant
with a real innovation
and creates an industry,
you will get maybe
a trillion dollar company.
And you'll have somebody who
becomes very, very wealthy.
AUDIENCE: Would you-- I'm
interested in your opinion.
Would you argue that
those first world problem
solvers are necessary steps to
allow the big players to exist?
Like if the market was
dominated first by the CRISPR--
AUDIENCE: I wouldn't
say it's necessary,
but I'd say that's
how it is right now.
And it's just been built on.
There's also a common strategy
where it seems really stupid
until it's not.
So it can also go
back and forth.
If you look at Silicon Valley.
Silicon Valley took 57 years
to become what it is today.
It really started off with
Stanford using their funding
from World War II, and
making a decision--
which was different than MIT's--
that I don't want to keep
the money inside the lab.
You built something,
you research it,
and then you go out and
make a company off of it.
But it takes a long
period of time.
And that was hard tech.
But it was just hard to scale.
Because what used to happen
is-- like in the '90s--
so if you wanted to make
computer science company, so
like something like
Facebook, there was actually
15 Facebooks before Facebook.
And what happened is
you'd have to buy servers,
you'd have to configure them.
And you'd probably spend about
like $100,000 to $750,000
to buy all your servers, right?
And then you got to
start it with the idea.
So like if somebody had to do
a Snapchat and be like, OK,
I paid a million dollars,
now I have to build it.
It's such a huge problem.
And so the issue, the reason
that hard tech didn't scale
before, is because you
would ask for that money,
and you would give up about 30%.
What would happen is the
founder would start the company,
and then what would
happen is because you
don't have any
management experience,
they'd kick you out.
So there wasn't much
control in the founder.
So now what's happened
is because of the funding
environment,
everybody has capital,
but there's very few good ideas.
And in fact, the
moniker of VCs is
that there's only really like
five really great companies
that we should
invest in this year.
So there's a lot of money.
And I would say that it's more
like, it's more like E News,
right?
All these companies you hear
of is just like scandal, just
like gossip tabloids.
There's a couple
of good companies
that every year will come out
and create really substantial
technologies, and
those are the people
that you won't hear about
today, you won't hear about them
a year from now.
But they'll be around 20 years
from now, 10 years from now.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you think
that capital system--
I mean, I imagine it would
need to change a bit once.
You start having
like IT companies
that are matching like
lot mid-scope workers
with the technology.
So say you have a VC person
that's interested in startups
right now in the
software industry.
They have like almost
100% profit margin,
now you start hiring people and
your profit margins are lower.
Do you think this
system that's being
put in place by what we have now
will be able to adapt for that?
AUDIENCE: Can you specify that
question a little bit more
and give an example?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So I think
you make an interesting point,
Matt, and this takes
us back to the reading
that we did about the
engine and cyclotron road.
And the fact that the venture
capital system in the US
is really focused on software
companies at this point.
And what Martin is
telling us is early stage,
the foundations
are built, they'll
able to move to
hard technologies.
We're not seeing
that yet, frankly.
Again, biotech is
a separate world,
and they've built a
system there by which
they can manage the scale up
with their current financial
model.
But I think there's--
you've given us a
hopeful perspective
of what could evolve.
AUDIENCE: I would say that
an example of now going
to the physical world
from the IT world
will be like in Uber
and Airbnb where
it's starting to filter
out, and then hard tech
will be a whole different field.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But the model
is still job
displacement, right?
And that's how you
get your return.
So it's a really
difficult model.
And we don't necessarily
have to go that way,
as we talked about
in the energy class.
A country like
Germany is organized
around manufacturing-led
innovation.
They're producing-- there's no
shortage of demand for goods
worldwide.
If anything, it's growing as
a lot of the developing world
becomes emerging economies.
And Germany is well positioned
to take advantage of that.
And they've just organized
their innovation system
very differently.
But Martin, you
make a good point.
This may be staging
that we could
move hard technologies into.
Much as I mean, biotech
is a separate world.
But CRISPR, in a
way, will result
in what we could
call hard, maybe
they're soft technologies
that could be in effect
a platform off an IT base.
How about another
question, Beth?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
So I think just
yesterday there was
an article in The Washington
Post or New York Times--
I forget-- talking about
how one of the downsides
to a lot of the lower paying
jobs that college graduates are
getting, such as
counseling or teaching,
is that they are harder
to displace by automation.
So they're talking about how
so many investment banking
jobs have already been
replaced by automation,
so you shouldn't feel
so bad that you're
taking a lower paying job
because it's a safer job.
And so this reminded me--
this question from Chris,
I think, gets to that.
So how do we accelerate
growth in these job areas
when we're admitting that
they're seemingly less
desirable right now for a lot
of people because they pay less?
And if these are the jobs
that maybe more people should
be going into, how do we
convince people to do that?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE]
there is an article [INAUDIBLE]
Washington Post about
how San Francisco is
creating teacher housing.
Because they felt like they
were getting a lot of stories
about how teachers
had to commute
in for several hours a day
into the greater Bay Area,
and then how some people
were living in people's
kitchens because they
couldn't afford the rent.
And so what San Francisco,
the municipal government, you
know again, the role of
municipalities, decided
was that they needed to
build housing specifically
for teachers.
This wasn't going to
be affordable housing,
this isn't going to
be low-income housing.
This is going to be housing
for teachers to live in so they
can teach at the schools.
And I feel like
perhaps there is going
to have to be sort of
additional incentives in terms
of infrastructure and
housing to support this,
I guess to support that
population of workers,
because it doesn't seem
like it's politically
viable to increase
salary, but it
does seem like a
reasonable proposition
to say, so long as you're
working for our schools,
and so long as you are
providing a public service that
is going to provide a
net benefit to society,
then you should have access to
housing and food, at a minimum.
AUDIENCE: Seems like--
remember that one article
you showed me about
unicorns, and how they're
very masculine and immature?
AUDIENCE: That is
not what it said.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, if you're
going to talk about--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
That's an unrelated topic.
AUDIENCE: No, no.
Because it has exit rounds and--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
AUDIENCE: --seed rounds.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I guess
I can also talk about.
Yeah, so I would be I would be
happy to send it to all of you
as well.
It was an article
that was written
by a woman on-- or two women
on Medium who had done research
on the unicorn economy, that
is the creation of a billion
dollar company.
And thinking about
how that's not
sustainable in the long run.
What we actually need to
be focusing venture capital
funds are our zebra
companies, which
are companies that
care not only about--
they're sort of like the triple
bottom line companies, right?
There is going to be a benefit
to the company economically,
there's going to be a benefit
to society economically,
and there's going
to be a benefit
to society as a result of the
product that they're creating.
And so they introduced
the zebra model,
because zebras are sort
of mutualistic animals
that travel in a
pack, as opposed
to these unicorns
that don't exist.
Right?
They're not real animals
that sort of promote
any sort of benefit
to the public.
And so I'd be happy
to pass it along.
AUDIENCE: I mean the article
makes a really good point
about how like these other
companies that are unicorns
are kind of like a
bull in a China shop.
They go and they ruin like a
lot of societal structures,
and they displace people,
and they don't really
consider it, or take
any consideration.
And how it kind of-- yeah, it
was an interesting article.
AUDIENCE: And the one
point that it doesn't hit,
I will underscore
for all of you,
is the way in which
companies like Uber,
and I think some of us know
this, but are essentially
informalizing our
economy, right?
Like, one of the things that
we treasure about economy
in the developed
world is that it
is a formal economy
in which people
have labor protections,
in which there
are trade unions,
in which workers
have rights and protections
against their employers,
and have that--
they can use their
citizenship as a means
of leveraging against
discrimination
that might occur to them in
the labor economy, right?
We, as wage laborers,
should get protections.
But the way that these
companies are introducing models
and perhaps, in Alibaba's
case, the kind that they're
bringing to the
US, is that they're
removing the labor protections.
So what happens if you
expose citizens to--
or if you revert citizens
from wage laborers
with protections to informal
laborers who sort of are
itinerant in the economy.
I mean, that's an
incredible consideration.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Look, we went through
in the 19th century.
I mean, with the advent
of industrialization there
were no worker protections.
And massive problems
with the workforce.
We've all read Dickens.
So we went through
that phase, and will
more formalized
protection systems
evolve over time, even
for the unicorn world?
Let's move to David Autor
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
All right, so as we
kind of mentioned,
Autor seems to be
slightly less concerned
with the immediate
impacts of automation.
But Lily pointed out that there
is some really startling job
loss in some sectors.
So even if some of
these jobs are replaced,
if we see an entire sector, such
as the retail sector, collapse,
is that something that the
economy can bounce back from?
What does that mean
for social order?
I mean, we've already seen
the effects of manufacturing
downturns have had pretty
dramatic effects on social ways
that we are
constructing ourselves.
So even if we can replace
some of these jobs,
what do you think that means
for the rest of society?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Here's a trick.
Ask Lilly since she
wrote the question.
AUDIENCE: Well, I was just
thinking about it because--
I don't know-- my
husband was listing to me
more than a dozen
retail companies
that are entering bankruptcy.
I think JCPenney,
Sears, et cetera.
Retail stores that are huge
and employ a lot of people.
And we thought of
as like staples
in our economy and
our consumer needs.
Also, there is talk of the
mall industry going under.
Just this like-- because
people don't go to the mall
like they used to all the time.
So I'm just wondering
if those are
going to have almost a
domino effect of well,
a couple of retailers
not that impactful,
not that big of a deal.
But then if you start to think
about the infrastructure that's
built up around malls, even
the parking lots for malls,
like what's going
to happen to those?
What are we going to
replace them with?
I just think it might
get a little desolate?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I would
look into vacancies in malls.
The way I would do it
was like, if everything
was statistical analysis
of the malls in the US,
and if they have vacancies.
Because what I'm pretty
much thinking is probably
would happen is like the
JCPenney model was optimized
for the '90s, and
it didn't evolve
into what the new consumer
needs would turn more niche.
And so they just lost their
edge and are losing money.
But there's probably
new stores like Lush
or like Kroger coming in
and taking over those.
That's probably what I
think that the business
models of the past
have been disrupted,
and now there's new
people coming in.
Because people
still go to malls--
AUDIENCE: But what if Lush,
say like, you know how people--
I actually don't
shop at Lush, but I
know that they make
the products in stores.
I mean, what if machines
come into Lush, and then
the products, I mean the
laborers become irrelevant?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
My little sister loves Lush.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
I think you're
making an important point
there, Martin, which
is that there may well be ways
to adapt a face-to-face store
model to these new realities.
And there's a slew of companies
that are actually working hard
on doing exactly this.
AUDIENCE: I mean--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
And then there's
a whole set of companies
that specialize
in kind of last year's goods.
Think TJ Maxx, right,
that are thriving, right?
And suppose you built
your mall around--
AUDIENCE: H & M.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
--a combination
of those two models.
Maybe that's a more
interesting mall model.
So again, I'm not sure.
I think we've got to
keep in mind just how
fast these changes are upon us,
and what the strategies are.
I think David Autor would argue
that there's a new delivery
model emerging here, right?
A new kind of role for
people that's just like we
saw with the ATM machines,
that's actually a significantly
upgraded kind of occupation.
And can we move on
those kinds of steps,
right, and then readjust some
of the existing models for that?
I mean, it's an open question.
In this piece in The
Economist this week,
which I recommended
earlier, reiterates
some of the things
you were raising,
Lily, which is
that there's going
to be a lot of grief
in malls unless they
get their models sorted out.
And they note a
number of examples
of models of malls that are
actually working to do that.
AUDIENCE: I think there's
two main things happening
that are probably going to
be disruptive to retailers.
Because I've studied retail for
a bit looking at a whole market
analysis.
And there's a reason
Amazon's going to retail,
is because all of e-commerce
is only 30% of what people buy.
People still buy like,
and go to places.
It's just a lot better.
They get to see it,
they get to feel it.
And that's why they go to malls.
Their disruption though,
is that they're not
going to really have workers.
I don't know if you've
seen how they're
going to do their stores.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: The other--
that's one disruption where
if you don't have employees.
But issues like
teenagers, right?
Like, it's not--
I don't know if somebody
expects to raise
a family on like an H & M
salary, or like a Zara salary.
The second disruption would
be 3D printers, and what
it does when you do materials,
and when you do like, fashion,
even.
Because if you go into a store--
because most of their
cost is all inventory.
And it leads to a
lot of logistics.
If I can make my store in such
a way that you can come in
and you'll get a tailored
dress is probably better
because it's very unique and
you can make like a 3D printer
for a dress, that'd
be really cool.
And somebody can go in
and get a perfect dress
based on their style,
based on a picture
that they have on
their like, Instagram.
Then you don't have inventory
and they can sell it
at like a decent price,
and it would probably
be a relatively
cheap dress, right?
Or if you can go and
get a tailor-made suit
if you're a guy, and it's
like perfect for you,
and it costs you like, $100,
$200, and it's in the fabric
that you want.
Especially with
synthetic fabrics.
I don't know if we talked
about in this class-- well,
we talked about in
the industrial center.
But those are the
big disruptions.
Or if you're like,
instead of having--
being an auto store, instead
of having all the inventory
that cost a lot of money, and
it gets old, and it gets rusty,
you can build a part when
somebody comes in exactly
for their car because you
have the data for that piece.
That's the big disruption.
And it will-- and
it's like-- it'll
be quick toppling of a
lot of core businesses
that-- because
all you have to do
is look at their balance
sheet, see where they spent all
their money, and then you
make that your business model
as a startup completely
the opposite.
And then they cant'
compete against you.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
against this backdrop,
remember, too, that the entire
movement of computer-like goods
was towards these big box stores
in distant low-cost suburbs
with gigantic parking lots.
That was the entire
movement of that sector.
Until Apple completely
reinvented the model,
and decided that, let's have
fabulous face-to-face, highly
personal, employee-heavy,
great service,
beautiful designed stores.
It is the most valuable
retail property
in the planet is an Apple Store.
There's nothing like it, right?
They've managed to create
more value per square foot
than any real estate magnate
ever dreamed of, right?
Again, through a very
different kind of model,
and again, taking advantage
of a new kind of way
of looking at employees,
and in effect,
upskilling that
whole employee base.
So these are ways in
which David Autor would
argue are ways of creating
complementarity to these new,
evolving technologies.
How about one more
Auto question then?
AUDIENCE: Perfect.
So the other kind
of controversial, or
thought-provoking topic that's
brought up in these articles
was the idea that if we reach
a state where so many jobs are
eliminated and
automation takes over,
we'll really be in
a state of abundance
rather than deficiency.
So they bring up
the idea of we'll
still have to figure out
how to allocate these goods,
and allocate how much money
people have even there's
no jobs for working.
So I think that's a pretty crazy
thing to think about right now.
But I'd be interested
to hear what you
think could happen with that.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
In other words, if we're
aiming at ever more efficient
production, we're going to
create productivity gains,
which in turn generate
new resources in a society
that you could use for
additional societal well-being.
So that's the
society-wide picture.
But then if you
look at it in terms
of a particular line of
goods, or a particular region,
there is more wealth potentially
being created, right,
for any given line of goods.
And that indeed
can be distributed,
and that can be a part of
a new kind of employee,
a new kind of
generation of employees,
and what their return is.
AUDIENCE: Mm-hmm.
So I guess, kind of what do you
see as a hypothetical picture
for how that would work?
Is this something
that the government
would have to kind of regulate?
Is this coming from the markets?
AUDIENCE: Are you talking
about like universal income
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Anybody have interest in that?
No, I'm not too socialist.
AUDIENCE: I was going
to make an analogy.
I have heard this is a fact.
I have not done
research on it so I
don't know if it's speculation,
but the way in which
the diamond industry
operates, which
is that there is an
abundance of diamonds,
but there is a
control of the market,
and thus they raise the price
on the diamond significantly.
And so the reason I bring
this as an example in which
to draw a parallel is because
universal basic income,
and the both of you, I think
the place where both of you
are coming from, is an
assumption that people
want to distribute
those resources, right?
And that people
want other-- that we
want to create those
productivity gains
rather than decrease, or rather
if we increase our productivity
gains, then we
won't act upon them.
And I don't necessarily--
I don't know if that's true.
And that's, I think my concern.
AUDIENCE: Can you clarify?
AUDIENCE: Like, just because
we can make more, say, food.
Just because we will have the
capacity to make more food
doesn't mean we will.
Just because we have
the capacity to--
AUDIENCE: Or doesn't mean that
everyone will be, on a whole,
healthier.
AUDIENCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Oh yeah.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Just because we will have
access to more things,
and we will have more rapid
access to these goods,
does not mean that
it will be a--
that people will have access to
them, or that it will be like
you were saying a
good thing overall.
AUDIENCE: I mean I
think the idea of giving
people hope that if
they lose their job
their whole life isn't
going to really, really suck
and they'll be
poor is important.
I don't know if universal basic
income would be the best thing,
just because the incentives.
And I think that will be really
a question of our generation.
Like, how do you make sure
that these people end up
having a place in society,
and being productive?
And not going into depression,
or not spending their days just
like not doing anything.
Like, how do you--
I think a big thing that will
have to happen, probably,
is that governments, or
even private organizations,
because governments now might
not be adequate at this,
will need to figure
out key business
opportunities for
micro entrepreneurs
that could give them
sustainable income,
and give them the
ability to capital lines
so that they'd be able to
generate wealth and create
businesses in areas that
need these businesses.
Because I think a lot of the
problem is in businesses.
Like, you start a business
and you don't know
if you will succeed or not.
But if somebody
could do an analysis
like they do for McDonald's,
where it's like, OK,
we know this area this
will be successful.
We know there's a need.
The government probably
knows where there's needs.
If you can do an
analysis to figure out--
data to figure
out, OK, a company
that does this would
be really useful here,
a company that does this
would be really useful here.
These will be the requirements.
You can do a franchise model
for people to start companies.
I'm not against like
universal basic income.
I just worry about the
incentives of not having
the ability-- or maybe
you create an incentive
that you study and
you become a teacher.
It's a thing that, no
matter what you say--
I can say like what it is, but
it's more about how you do it.
Because you could
incentivize and create
more teachers, but if you
don't respect those teachers,
or if they don't value them,
then it'll be very weird.
If you create it and
people just use the money
and build these businesses,
and they're really
going out and having
fun, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: I think for me,
universal basic income is one
of those things where like
economists really talk about
and we can, in a sense, there's
like a lot of literature
and kind of journal articles
kind of fielding this idea like
what if we don't.
But in the US,
I'm trying to see,
if we have this sort of
widening of this barbell effect,
where we had this erosion
of this middle class,
and kind of like this large--
like, basically the
people getting rich
aren't increasing in
number fast enough,
but like, there's
a lot of people
kind of regressing this way.
And so I'm trying to see like,
what are the conditions that
will allow for us to call
for a universal basic income?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Rashid,
I think you're really
onto an important point here.
If you've got a declining
middle class, their incentives
to, in effect, take money
out of their own incomes
and redistribute them,
that's going to be a problem.
If that's a threatened
community, which increasingly
it is, then politically, that is
a very difficult step to take.
So I would argue
that we probably
need to look at education,
which is a great way
to lead into our next reading.
So another terrific
David Autor piece.
David, for my money is doing
the best work in economics
anywhere.
This is his-- this builds
on the Goldin and Katz piece
that we talked about
in the last class,
right, and kind of takes it
another kind of step further.
And this piece is
all about skills,
and education, and the rise
of earnings inequality.
And now, there is a
steep and persistent rise
of earnings inequality
in the US labor
market that has been going
on for more than a couple
of decades now.
And it's not just true
in the United States.
This is a phenomenon in the
developed world in general.
But why look at inequality?
And what do we start to see?
First, the earnings
premium for education
has risen very significantly
as we talked about last week.
So 2/3 of the overall rise of
earning dispersion between 1980
and 2005 is accounted for by
this increased premium that's
associated with
schooling in general,
and post-secondary
education in particular.
So let me just jump
to a slide of this.
So this is a projection
that comes out
of the quite respected
Georgetown University
Center on Education
and Workforce, which
does really first-rate
work on the workforce.
And they found that looking at
what projections were for 2024,
they found that in
terms of job openings,
high school diploma and less
than a high school diploma
was going to be about
19.7 million job
openings in that time period.
Job openings for those with
college associate degrees--
some college associate degrees
and college plus college--
36.5 million jobs, right?
So this is a profound
upskilling of the workforce
that's going on.
And look, by the way, the
higher education system
isn't necessarily going
to produce these numbers.
So what that means is that
the people on this end
are going to be able to charge
a premium because there's
going to be a shortage of
demand for their skill sets.
That's what's going on.
That's what David
Autor is telling
us has been going on now for
several decades in the US.
It's exactly that phenomena.
And the earnings gap, then,
between college and high school
graduates has more than
doubled in the United States
over the last three decades.
So lifetime earnings expectation
with a college degree
is now very powerful compared
to your lifetime earning
expectation if you have
a high school degree.
And the skill
premium concept here,
offers real insight into
the evolution of inequality
in the US society.
Now of course, this is all
related to the employment
issues, and particularly
the future employment
issues that we've just
been talking about.
One more statistic
that underscores this.
This is the fall
in real earnings.
In a Hamilton project study
that was done for Brookings,
this is the percentage
of real earnings
in working age from 1990 to
2013 for men aged 30 to 45.
No high school diploma,
median income decline
went down 20 points
in that time period.
High school diploma down 13
points in that time period.
So we've got a profound
societal issue.
This is just a big signal
of an inequality problem
that's a problem now, and
because of the phenomenon
we've just been talking about
in two previous readings.
Is potentially going to get
significantly worse over time.
So this is a big
societal dilemma
that you guys are going to
have to figure out, right?
And it looks like Autor is
telling us that a lot of this
has to do with the
education system.
How are we going to
alter the education
system to move a lot of people
to higher levels of education?
How is that phenomenon
going to work?
What are we going to do
in terms of designing
new institutions and new
mechanisms to do that?
So the rising demand
for educated labor
in advanced economies, including
the US, it's a profound rise.
And if the supply
of educated workers
doesn't keep pace with the
persistent outward shifts
in demand for the
skills, then you just
multiply your
inequality problem.
And it forces a public policy
response around upskilling,
right?
That's a societal task we're
going to have to accomplish.
Now, Rashid pointed out,
I think very astutely,
that, with this
barbell phenomena,
which is another David
Autor concept, right,
that the society looks
increasingly like a barbell.
You've got a very successful
and growing upper middle class,
you've got the middle
of the economy,
which is being in
decline and being--
we just saw the
median income data--
and moving towards lower-end
service delivery jobs, right?
Personal service delivery
kinds of positions.
The politics of that make
it problematic to deal with,
say income distribution
in the United States.
It's just not going to
be politically simple.
If everybody was
rising together that's
an easier problem to tackle.
But they're not.
So education is probably
the way in which we're
going to have to address this.
All right?
We're going to have to
up skill that workforce.
And look, by doing that,
as Martin pointed out,
you're addressing the
underlying problem.
You're helping people
realize their talents
and their capabilities, right?
And that's, frankly,
a better solution
to the problem than just
throwing money at people,
I would argue, right?
It's probably not the
only thing you do,
and it's not going
to help everybody,
but can we find
strategies to do this?
So I've been working on this,
and I've been thinking about it
and talking to Sanjay Sarma,
who runs the online education
effort at MIT, and MIT has
developed these new platform
technologies.
MITx and edX is another
platform provider,
pervasive online capability.
But on the other hand,
it's hard to envision
a steelworker in
southeastern Ohio
who's lost their job, at
being willing or able to spend
a substantial amount of
time in front of a computer
blue screen in their basement
while their kids are running
around upstairs, right?
Just not terribly likely.
AUDIENCE: Or, if there was
a case brought up recently
that somebody was worried about
losing their job because they
would lose their insurance,
and their kid might not be
able to get proper [INAUDIBLE].
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Yes, the problems
multiply when you
get into this box.
And we've had two
recent-- recently two
very interesting
books that start
to portray this problem for us.
And so Hillbillology is a
very interesting story of one
of the big diasporas in US
history out of the South,
out of the Appalachians,
into industrial employment
in the Middle West.
And with the decline
of US manufacturing,
that community
really got nailed.
And what do you do
with that community?
This book is a pay-on
to that community,
and how to even think
about the kind of problems
they've got into.
Opioids are one example
cited in that book.
There's a new book just
out by Annie Goldstein
about a town in Wisconsin.
Town of about 60,000 people.
The major employer was
a General Motors plant
that employed 9,000 people.
It had survived the Rust
Belt. It was a quality plant.
But when General Motors
went bankrupt in 2008,
all those people lost their
jobs, every single one of them.
And it put that community--
tax revenues declined,
housing values
declined, everything
is going down, right?
Community services collapse,
charitable contributions drop,
right?
It's painful to watch what
happens in that community.
Finally, one good thing happens.
Dollar store opens a
distribution plant.
The jobs pay way less
than half of what
the General Motors jobs paid.
So that's the kind of problem
that we're up against here.
And in light of all
we've just been talking
about technological job
displacement occurring
over time, we've got
a big upskilling job
to do here, I would
argue, in our economy.
So online capabilities are
one piece, but that's not
going to be the answer here.
It's probably going
to be a blended model.
And can we think about how
to enlist community colleges,
and how to join them
with universities
developing curriculum?
And how do we know
what the curriculum is?
What's the content education
in a society that's going
to change the nature of work?
How do we begin to
understand that?
What's the changing nature of
work that these technologies
are going to drive?
How do we educate for that?
So we've got a big task ahead.
But a mix of employers,
community colleges,
universities, and
labor organizations
is probably going to be the way
we try to figure some of this
out.
So I'm just extrapolating
from David Autor's point
about the underlying
importance of education
to this inequality
problem, and emphasizing
that education is
probably going to be
the fix we're going to use.
But then, how are going
to do that, right?
So a big challenging problem.
So who's got this one?
Sanam, you want to lead
us through some questions?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Yeah, so a couple of points.
I thought the
focus on inequality
was really interesting
here, especially
he touches on briefly why
inequality is actually
good for innovation.
And this is something
that we talk
a lot of that in econ classes,
and how, of course there
are greater
incentives to be more
productive because the rewards
and returns are better.
And then also,
generally in countries
that have more unequal
distributions of income,
that attracts people
from other countries
with more equal distribution of
income to come to that country
and stay.
So in terms of attracting
talent for our innovation system
from abroad, it's actually
kind of a benefit.
But obviously there
are a lot of problems
as well that she talks about.
Especially the intergenerational
mobility problem.
So that there's a decline
in wages for people who
are not in college educated.
And that tends to perpetuate
within families and communities
as well.
So one of my big
questions here, which
is just kind of a
general question,
is how do we make sure
that in discussions
about innovation and
technological advancement,
that we address these problems
of systemic inequality, that
still persist in the country?
And kind of tying onto
that, to what extent
are the systems of privilege
of educational and skill
advancement in attainment
embedded in this framework
that we've been studying
throughout this semester?
So I kind of want to get
your thoughts on that.
AUDIENCE: Can you repeat that?
Just like the main question?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Why don't you
break them into the two pieces?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, sure.
So my first question was how--
in these discussions
we've been having
about encouraging innovation
and technological advancement,
how do we address problems of
systemic inequality as well?
AUDIENCE: Just for the
limiting down of your question,
would you mind
defining for us what
is systemic inequality
is in your definition?
Because I have my own very
many definitions, right, around
my field in political science.
And then, two, what
systemic inequalities
do you want to talk about?
Is it race?
IS it income inequality?
Is it social class?
Is it what durable inequalities?
AUDIENCE: Educational
disparities?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so I'm going
to go up with Autor's piece was
and talk about--
so by systemic
inequality he was talking
about how the
educational attainment
gap tends to persist
within families,
and then extrapolate that into
like larger communities which
these families are in.
And then it just kind of gets
perpetuated in that sense.
So I think, maybe
specifically talk
about like when it comes
to educational attainment,
and then the later on how
that translates into income
and into wages.
We can just talk about how that
kind of factors in [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Bernie had it right.
Free education.
That's the crux.
AUDIENCE: I think there's
an important point here
that you said about
intergenerational mobility
and educational attainment.
And now that there's
just this transition
in this additional premium
on like having a bachelors
and a post-secondary
degree that didn't exist,
but like it's sort of
too late to fix that once
you've already matriculated
sort of into the workforce.
And now, I mean, I don't have
my post-secondary or college
degree, but I'm 45 and I
have all these other problems
to deal with.
And so I think just
like maybe Bill
was starting to say, like
there are some fixes with maybe
community college and
kind of night classes
that are like sort
of kind of segues
back in to the system
of like getting back
that educational premium
that maybe you didn't have
the opportunity to previously.
And I think maybe
that's a lot easier
than these giant kind
of skill retraining
or repurposing maybe.
I can imagine like
a larger gym filled
with like computers that
kind of people come in
and like take online
classes of how to do
better or something like that.
But you really have to
focus, I would say, on
like there's this
large subset as we
saw in this last election of
people who have shifted out
of jobs, particularly
in manufacturing,
who are intergenerationally
speaking on
like the I've been out of
school or been out of college
for 20 plus years.
And like, is it too late for me
to go back, or switch, or gain
these skills, these
educational skills that I need?
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: Right.
So Rashid, I think you make
a very good point here.
We're going to need
that steelworker
I was talking about
before who lost
his job in southeastern Ohio.
He's not going to go back
and get a four-year degree
in college.
It is not going to happen.
Whether Bernie wants
to make it free or not,
Lily, it's not going to happen.
We need an entirely
different set
of institutional
models that's going
to work with this community.
And as we have this
technological job
displacement--
and I personally will talk
more about this later,
I don't think this is
going to be something
that happens tomorrow.
I think we've got time to
work on this, all right?
I think it's going to be a
more gradual process than some
of the technological
dystopians have portrayed.
But we're going to
have to use that time,
and I think we're
going to have to create
a whole new set of institutional
arrangements to begin to cope.
Otherwise, we're just leaving
too many people behind.
And the price in our society
and the price in our democracy--
as we just learned from the
last presidential election--
is pretty high.
That's my case, right?
That's what I want to work on.
But other of you I know
have thoughts on this.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Three small thoughts.
The first of which is that
this conversation is making me
think of education as a
sort of social security
for young people.
That's our social safety net.
AUDIENCE: Like it's
our insurance policy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
it's our insurance.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah.
And I mean I--
like I said earlier in the
semester, I took a course--
or I just finished yesterday,
a course in computer science.
And it was so hard.
I mean it was really
challenging and really positive
experience for me, personally.
But I also, as I was
doing these assignments,
considered what it would
be like to have a family
and to have obligations
beyond myself,
and to have to be
retrained in a vocation.
And that's almost
insurmountable.
I can't imagine what it would
be like for my father who
is a single income earner
in the service industry,
to lose his job and
to have to think
about the ways in which he can't
help our family anymore, right?
I come from a low-income family.
That's a consideration
I have to have.
And then secondly, about
not so much inequality,
but I did research for
a political science
course on global inequality
on waste pickers in the world,
and the role that they
play in the economy
specifically in solid waste
and the recycling process
in the global supply chain.
And one of the things
that came up a lot
was social exclusion
as the mechanism
by which inequality happens.
And I feel like we
need to talk more
about things in the terminology
of social exclusion,
because then we
understand how it happens
and who commits
the action, and who
is the receiver of the action.
AUDIENCE: What do you
mean by social exclusion?
AUDIENCE: So social exclusion
is preventing individuals
from accessing a sector as a
result of a durable inequality.
And so I'll break
that down further.
It's essentially in the
case of, say, waste pickers.
The way in which they have
been excluded in, say, Brazil,
from accessing education
because of their race.
Right?
So that's a very
complicated picture.
But what we can determine
is that because families,
in sort of the middle and
upper class in Brazil,
have always had
access to education,
they want to sustain
that standard of living
for their progeny.
And so then their
progeny gets educated.
But at the same
time, there's only so
many spots at the national
universities, right?
And so those spots
are never going
to go to the children of
the low income parents.
They're always going to go
to the wealthier families.
And if we think about things in
a process of social exclusion
rather than inequality,
which is the outcome
of social exclusion, I think
we can start rectifying some--
at least some of the
dimensions by which
we oppress other people.
Because it's really easy to
say, oh, there's inequalities,
and to identify all of them.
But I think it's
much harder to think
about the ways in which
we ourselves either
uphold those inequalities,
perpetuate those inequalities,
or benefit from those
inequalities, right?
And so we have to,
I think that if we
talk about things in the
language of exclusion,
there's almost a responsibility
and accountability
to the effects that
those exclusions have.
AUDIENCE: What's the third one?
AUDIENCE: And yeah I was
just-- that was little--
I've had a lot of thoughts
about that for a long time.
But I think it's
really important
that we are accountable
for the ways in which we
benefit from inequalities.
And I'm not an exception.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I had a quick point,
but if yours is quick.
I think to Steph's
point just super quick.
I think there are
a lot of studies
that say like,
inequality in a sense
like we're OK with, like,
it's OK that Martin makes
more money than I did this week,
like, we're all OK with that.
But I think in the
rising inequality,
in this barbell effect,
like, you have people--
like this growing
subset of people
who just aren't earning as much.
And there's sort
of a lot of them.
And there's not really this
distribution of inequality,
then we get to say, we
have more reason to say,
like, I'm not OK with
once I have less.
And then I think there's a
difference between inequality
and unfairness, which I think
Steph was trying to get at.
And it's when unfairness
in a sense like,
I didn't have the
same opportunity
that Martin did to
get to that point.
Like, I didn't have the
same college education
that Martin did to get to
that point, that's sort
of when these problems arise.
And I think once we
have this rising--
we have sort of a rising
sentiment of inequality,
and I think it's going
to be a lot easier for us
to say that these systems
are sort of bringing things
that are kind of on the whole.
And so the systems are unfair
and causing these inequalities,
and now we can have, I'm going
to say political pressure,
and not kind of
the social impetus
to really change things.
AUDIENCE: I'll make one
quick point on this paper,
and then one on just inequity.
So what's interesting
to me about this paper
is that there is another
article that came out
about inequality in education.
On, it was like one of
the major publications,
like Time or Wall
Street Journal.
And what they did is they looked
at people who actually went
to college that were
minorities or from low income
versus high income.
Yeah.
But what they did
is they mapped where
they were like in the future.
And it turned out that it was
pretty much the same, right?
So they don't go up the ladder.
And so what I question
when I see something
like this is like, OK, well
if you actually go and get
a college education are
you better off financially?
And is that the
metric of success?
You might get personal
fulfillment, better lifestyle.
But I think it's a
flawed idea to say
if you go to college
you will end up
making more money that way.
Because it might have
been based on the paradigm
then in the '50s, yeah,
you'd get a really good job,
and you have great benefits.
But to start to say that,
OK, if you go to college
then you'll be set.
And then to say, OK, we
just need to get everybody
through college.
That's a very big
bubble mentality.
And I think we'll be
paying very heavily for it.
I just recently saw an
interview on like Goldman Sachs,
and how they saw the
financial crisis.
And they explained
it in terms of, well,
we built the road, right?
But when we were giving
out these securities,
we didn't make decision
put our money into them.
It was all these
people were trying to--
they thought that this
was the factor to success
and kept buying them
and buying them.
Every time they bought one
they would crack the road,
crack the road, crack the road.
But we had the duty to give
certain kinds of bonds,
and other people sold them
again, which we didn't do.
And so ultimately we get--
it's easy to point the finger at
us because the road was broken.
But it's because the
actions of individuals
buying, and buying, and
buying, going into grief.
And so I think that's
an interesting point.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: So that
is an example of a bubble
economy [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: A bubble
economy, yeah.
And also this point--
and I think Stephanie's point--
I forget which one--
on, oh, the insurance policy
was made by Peter Thiel
in 2010 about why--
he questioned if
you go to college
would you be better off?
And so that's not an
inequality of education.
On the issue of inequity what
I find really interesting
is that we talk about
equality, but we're
living in a relatively
prosperous time.
Also, the US, it is a
land of opportunity.
And so I thought it was really
interesting, or even ironic
during the 1%
movement, that it was
like the 1% of the world
getting angry at the 1%.
And it is this
thing that we have
this kind of social
contract that in the US
you will be able to
advance and move forward.
But I think inequity
is a big issue.
Like, how do you make it
so that people can move up?
Warren Buffett talks
about the lottery of life.
That say you were about to
be born in five minutes.
If you had to design
the world any which way,
and you don't know
if you're going
to be born a woman,
a man, if you're
going to be born
disabled, if you're going
to be born mentally retarded.
AUDIENCE: With a
mental disability.
AUDIENCE: Or if you're
going to be born--
you know what I mean.
If you would be born
somewhere else in the world
where you don't
have an opportunity
and you have to pick up scraps
for the rest of your life.
What kind of world would
you want to create,
and how do you go
building about that world?
And I think that's a
really interesting way
of looking at it.
Because really, I don't think
equal outcome I don't think
will ever be a thing.
And to say that that will be
a thing is a very flawed idea
and would just
lead to self-anger,
and you will get
jealousy of other people.
There's also things in
life that you can't buy.
If you focus on
building that, if you
build great relationships,
if you're good to people
they'll be good to you.
Because there's a
lot of billionaires
that everybody hates them.
You can look at the
President, right?
And so I think
that's a big issue.
And there's just been that--
well, there's also the idea
of a capitalist society
where we have to have
these figureheads that
made a lot of money.
And we have to have
the proper incentive
to want to become like them.
And we have to push that--
that's why the system is built
for us to want to revere people
on the Forbes list, so
that we can continue
growing capitalistically.
But I think definitely what
will happen-- especially
my generation-- is
people are going
to start to question capitalism,
especially the issues
that Marx brought up.
So that we'll say, how
do we build a better
capitalist system where
we can be better humans?
Or there might be a lot
more assholes, I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Also to Martin's
point about your college degree
may not be the
right path, or it's
kind of hazardous to say that if
we just give everyone a college
degree and kind
of subsidize that,
they'll just make higher
incomes and like everything
will be fine.
I think there's-- and I can't
remember which slide it was.
Like, what percent-- like
what degree level and like
how it affects your income.
AUDIENCE: The change
in real earnings?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
change in real earnings.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: This one?
AUDIENCE: This one.
AUDIENCE: Seems uneven.
AUDIENCE: It seems uneven.
But I think there's something
to be said about kind
of generational nobility here.
So like those who had a
bachelors degree coming out
in maybe 1970 or a
little bit earlier,
that income level was
relative to the time.
Like, it allowed me
to live comfortably,
whereas my bachelor's
degree now,
and whatever bump in
income level I get, like,
am I living comfortably?
Am I going to be
able to subsist?
And that might be
like an indicator
where it's like, yeah,
it's unequal in here,
but like there's actually a
bigger social problem here.
So even though I might be
making more than I was in 1990,
like is my 1990 salary, at
that level is it enough for me
to live in 1990?
And like, is my 2013
salary, is that enough?
AUDIENCE: These are
real earning, right?
So these are
inflation adjusting.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Inflation adjusted, but
like cost of living.
AUDIENCE: There's
also one factor
I think is really important.
And I think the recent
election showcased--
were you done with your point?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
No, I'm done.
AUDIENCE: Which is, I think the
real issue happening right now
is that we are in a stagnation
in terms of actual real term
prospect-- like real
prosperity growth.
The numbers can say we grew,
but everything costs a lot more.
The way the system is
created to show that, oh,
we're doing well.
I think like the
poverty line, right,
is flawed the way we're
calculating it now,
because it's not really
showing what people
can buy with what they have.
And that's how we create it.
Because everything costs a lot
more, but they've adjusted it
and they've fudged the
numbers in such a way
that it seems to be
kind of a big picture.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
So we're going to--
Martin, we're going
to get into this
when we get to the last
reading and lay out
this whole issue of
secular stagnation,
and what the implications
of that historically
low productivity rate we're at,
and historically low investment
rates that we're at.
And that may be--
I think you're about
to drive at this--
that may be a really, big
time, near time problem.
Whereas the technological job
displacement maybe a little
further off.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well,
yeah, I was going
to finish with when
people don't see
like what is going
to be the next step,
they kind of start
to lose hope and they
start fighting over things
that really are non-issues.
This happens in a lot-- it's
a common organizational thing.
When you lose your
vision, people
start fighting
over really like--
very intensely--
about things that
maybe don't matter as
much, or wouldn't have been
an issue when they had vision.
And I think that's
one of the reasons we
see such intense
infighting right now.
Because we're really
starting to question
like what will-- well,
not really question,
but we should just
see America as it is,
and no one has said
this what America
will be 50 years
from now and we'll
start working towards that.
And I think that's a big factor
that I saw in the last four
years.
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
Sanam, you want
to give us a closing point after
all of our discussions on this?
AUDIENCE: There's a
slight point, I think.
We might be able to
talk about later,
but like the GI Bill as like--
I wanted to mention it as
like the last big, kind
of governmentally-subsidized,
like, real movement
towards kind of educating
en masse a large subset
of the population for
the sake of education
and all the other reasons.
But there's [INAUDIBLE]
if I didn't say,
there's a whole subset of like
social inequities that exist
within the GI Bill that we
don't have to get into, but--
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN:
But you're right.
I mean, the two mass
higher education
bills that the US did--
so the Land Grant College
Act that created, in effect, the
institutional base, and the GI
Bill that took this huge
population returning from World
War II and stuck
them in college,
those created gigantic
returns for the society.
So I understand
your point, Martin,
which is that just
getting a college degree
doesn't necessarily fit you
for the life worth living.
I think we will
all agree on that.
But it sure helps.
It sure moves you a step up.
AUDIENCE: Better
than [INAUDIBLE]..
WILLIAM BONVILLIAN: And
gets you closer in range.
Sanam, how about a closing
thought from you on this,
and we'll take a short break.
AUDIENCE: I think it's a lot
of good points, definitely.
And I think that when
we're thinking about policy
and how to move
forward, the discussion
about systems of
privilege and exclusion
are really important as well.
And also to think about
kind of like what can we
define as success both
individually and as a system
is also an interesting
and problematic thing
that we should
continue to talk about.